don't mind me I'm just shuttling
pictures of computer barb people's basis
it's not at all weird Oh in the last
video we talked about how do you find
faces quickly in an image that's I guess
nowadays only half the story if you want
to unlock a face of your phone or you
want to unlock it with your computer or
you want to just recognize who's in a
picture that's face recognition not face
detection
we can't just train a classifier we
can't just say here's 1,500 images of
Shawn and 1,500 images of Mike what work
out what the difference is because it
will do that and then I'll say well
here's a picture of Steve and it will go
Mike
you know because it's only got two
options like so then we have to retrain
it and you'll notice that when you sign
up for your phone the first time and it
recognizes your face it doesn't have to
train a network right because that would
take way too long how does it do it will
be answer is basically we train a
network to distinguish the differences
between faces rather than actually
recognizing individual faces I've got
some printer here with his max here's me
Shawn and Dave and so on right I've got
lots of lots of computer power hosts in
here so what I could do is I could say
well here's a picture of Max and here's
a picture of Mike so I have some you
know some convolutional layers or
something and I have a network here and
that goes all the way deep network up to
a classification but lights up with Max
or Mike the problem is that we bring in
Shawn and everything's ruined
you're put in a funny face that doesn't
help the standard way of training a
network which is giving it an image and
a label and saying learn to be better
with predicting that isn't going to work
because we don't know how many people
are going to use this system we can't
put them all in all right otherwise
companies have been tapping you up for
face pictures before they even release
the phone we say well why don't we train
a network to instead of saying bitties
definitely someone to just say these are
their features right and hopefully when
we if it's good at it it will say that
their features are different to someone
else's features that's the idea so what
we're actually doing is we're training a
network to separate people out let's say
you put me in and this network that I'm
designing has a lot of layers in it all
the way along here but instead of
outputting a single decision as to who
this is it outputs a series of numbers
so let's say a vector of numbers here
like this I didn't maybe matter how many
there are for now and what we're saying
is when we put me in
these numbers need to be different than
when we put Maxine or when we put let's
see who else we got Dave right when we
put Dave in his numbers come out
different to mine right and it's those
numbers which are kind of like a
fingerprint for each person so how do we
do this well we use a special kind of
learning or a special kind of loss
function called a triplet loss right all
this is one of the ways you can do it
there were a few so what we say is we
say what we put in three images at once
so we say here's two images of me and
one image of Dave and what we want to do
if we want to change the network so that
when we put these fujas through these
two are rated very similar and these two
pairs are rated is very different and
actually what we'd usually do is we
label this one and anchor this one a
positive sample and this one a negative
sample so we're saying but a distance
between these two has to be very similar
and the distance between these has to be
very far apart so let's imagine it was
only two numbers out so we're putting
ourselves on a sort of 2d grid right so
this this is variable one and this is
available to that come out of our
network right so this is our network
like my anchor is is a picture of me a
positive sample and a negative sample
which is Dave right so I put them
through the network and what we trained
it to do is separate out the pictures of
me in the pictures of Dave so I maybe
get put over here so I get a very high
value for - and a very low value for
number one let's say all right Dave gets
a very high value for number one and a
very low value for number two and then
we start to repeat this process with
different pairs of people and different
positives and different negative samples
so let's say I mean why did I shuffle
these that's a real okay so let's say
two pictures of op miles that's why he's
not nice to avoid my printer and one
picture of Sean right so maybe what
miles gets put over here near me which
is not so good but we'll get to that and
then you're put over here like this and
then maybe later on we have two pictures
of me and one of Rob which moves Rob
down here a little bit and then Dave
gets put over here and you know max gets
put over here somewhere negative values
are also allowed and what we're trying
to do is make sure that everyone is
nicely separate okay now if you do this
for just a few people what you're
actually doing is just classifying them
but if you do this for thousands of
different humans of all different
ethnicities and different poses and
different lighting conditions
eventually the network is going to start
to learn how to I mean actually that's
not right because Dave's far away from
Dave right so hopefully we start to come
together but that's you've got a train
for a long time
and let's not let Steve off the hook is
Steve over here high value of two high
value of one whatever that means the
interesting thing about this is we're
not performing a classification which is
performing a dimensionality reduction
we're saying how do we represent people
as just these two numbers right or in
the case of actual deployments of this
maybe 128 or 256 numbers somewhere in
this space when you put my face in I'll
appear and when you put Steve's face in
it'll peer somewhere else and this
actually solves a really nice problem
right it's called the one-shot learning
problem how do we convince a phone to
let me in having only seen one ever
picture of my face which is when I first
you know calibrated it the first time
and the answer is we don't train a
neural network to classify me we just
use the existing network that we trained
on thousands of thousands of people
doing this to put me somewhere on here
and then we record that location and
then when I come in again and try and
unlock the phone do does my new image go
to the same place in this space as my
last one so let's say I get put over
here with a high value of two and a low
value of one I take another picture of
myself on my camera and I come in over
here and it goes well that's pretty
close okay we'll let them unlock the
phone right but max comes in and gets
put over here that's judged as to higher
difference and access is denied right
this is how it works
and this is really clever because it
means that the actual decision making
process on whether you're allowed in or
not it's based on just the distance of
these numbers right in which case is
like 128 numbers sure this is
susceptible to problems yeah so it is
and this is one of the things that Apple
for example with their face ID have yeah
if you bear in mind of course haven't
told me how they do it right so nor
would they but we can presume it works
something like this we have a depth
camera as well but they will have
included in their training set pictures
of people in masks and pictures of
people with different hair and pictures
of people in strange locations and
things so the network learned to ignore
those things right if you never showed
it to the network you're right B will
just miss classifier all the time that's
that's the problem if you only train
this to separate me in day
when you put Steve in its behavior is
going to be undefined right so but
that's kind of how neural networks work
they often undefined you hope that you
put in a good enough training set so but
for the vast majority 99.999% of cases
it works very consistently and it says
no they come out over here which is not
close enough so we're not unlocking the
phone the interesting thing is it's much
harder to gain this system than it is to
gain a system based on simple
decision-making right so yes you might
be able to trick this to unlock a phone
once or twice right but if you try and
recreate that same process with my face
and unlock my phone for example maybe
you won't have as much luck because
exactly how its network works isn't
clear even to the people that chain to
trained it which is quite kind of its
strength in this case right maybe it's
security for obscurity right maybe
there's a certain thing you can hold up
in front and it'll always unlock right
it doesn't seem very likely but we don't
know until we find those things so it's
the air as an interesting one for
further study I guess you were
mentioning these features here people
will ensure that as what can arise we've
got all the hair we've got I mean is
that what's going on okay we don't know
right so we call this feature space for
latent space it's a kind of space just
before classification where it's you've
got features but these features in a
deep network are or mean we've had a
look at sort of inside and your network
before and they kind of a sort of
combinations of edges and things like
this it is going to be bored leaf or
something trained on human faces it's
going to be broadly the kind of face
related features because otherwise it
wouldn't work as a as a trained network
but exactly what it does we don't know
does it wait hairs more important than
eye color I don't know and neither do
the people that run it I expect they're
trained with different haircuts so so
that they forego this kind of issue but
of course you have to be careful doing
that right because if you can shave your
head and still unlock the phone is that
as secure as a phone but you couldn't do
that on my it's not usable so that's the
other reason they do it but you get the
idea
but you've noticed from this two
dimensional space which I've done just
for simplicity it becomes difficult to
separate out everyone in this space so
who else have we got
so you're in here you're in over here so
maybe your images are here blobs images
are here they start to take up quite a
lot of room one
got a few of them and that's a bit of a
weird one right so that goes over here
and and and maxes over here so it's
getting a bit cluttered right so the
decision on whether to unlock a phone
becomes more difficult so we don't
usually do this in two dimensions we do
it in 128 or 256 dimensions so but
spacing these things out for many many
people is much much easier I would say
that it's likely that someone on earth
will be able to unlock someone's phone
like this because they look similar
enough to them but the chances of that
person being the one that steals your
phone is pretty slim so I really
wouldn't worry about it too much and
this pixel was going to be always three
so that's going to be 12 14 23 and now
we fast forward while I do a bit of math
in my head 8 on a computer this is much
much faster likely to be on a network
which is limited in what it can connect
to it's probably likely to be able to
connect to other board management
controllers on the same network